what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
another episode of pearl daily where I
cover this week's treachery debauchery
and craziness today we have a special
guest on the
show
Welcome hi introduce yourself to the
people hello hello I am Shahara also
known as the female skeptic I have a new
name online name and uh yeah I'm happy
to be back I came a few times
on the show and uh looking forward to
talking about what's what nonsense you
have for me today yes yes so um a little
background you know you're you're
actually studying to be a lawyer yes I
am I am a student of law I'm very
passionate about men's rights
particularly father's rights and I work
very closely with Charity which we're
hoping to take the child maintenance
service to court though really so what
would that look like it's like a mass
lawsuit
yeah so it's uh it's called like a group
litigation so
uh basically like U various people come
together and we take one lawsuit against
the CMS okay um under an organization
called split the difference okay so and
how do people if they want to be a part
of it how do they contact it oh yeah um
absolutely they can visit split theed
difference.com okay and all the
information is there so you have been
coming on the show for over a year now
yes yes veteran yeah veteran and I was I
was just telling you before the show so
she has such a calming energy that
you've never been on a crazy show no no
I I I thank God yeah um okay so um guys
before we start make sure you like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams um so let's try to get this
video to 2,000 likes also guys make sure
you subscribe to the channel we're
trying to get to 2 million before the
end of the Year okay so um the first
story do you have any idea who Lana
rhods is no I don't okay so Lana rhs is
a porn star and when she was 18 she
started doing porn she did it for about
um she said she did like two stints of
four months so she only did really a
year okay but in that year she just
became like a very I guess well-known
porn star um and then after she quits
porn and she becomes a social media
influences and she is a girl that has
denounced porn like she said she was
manipulated which I don't
really I don't really B like sometimes I
just think chicks kind of say that to
dodge accountability right um I think it
was a poor choice I think she
acknowledges that yeah but I I don't
sometimes I'm like I I don't know how
like I've never seen her stuff but I
guess it was pretty graphic like like I
guess it was pretty good God yeah like I
I I can't remember the story they T I
don't even think I want to know but it
it was something like very like I think
it was extreme even for po oh my God
yeah like I know I know um okay so um
she actually ended up dating Logan
Paul's friend Mike so Logan Paul's a
best friend Mike they dated um I guess
he was a former drug addict she's a
former porn star they come together kind
of broken yeah you know whatever they it
ends up not working out
she ends up getting pregn oh no with
someone's kid not his not his no someone
else is they break up okay right okay
now we don't know who it is okay it's
speculated that it's an NBA star right
okay so now she is a single
mother
shocking it's interesting because I've
seen Clips too of her talking that about
that she used to be married before as
well wow you know to a prison I guess I
guess my God how old she um she I think
she's around my age so I think she's
around like 20s maybe like yeah so she's
lived a lot of life but I think she got
married at
18 ends up divorcing the husband he was
too controlling which is interesting so
I'm like well I I don't know you might
have been better off married to the
prisoner right I don't usually recommend
that life path but I'm like if we're if
these are the
options yeah do you know what I mean
like oh it sounds like cuz you're saying
that she made so many mistakes and she
doesn't you know she what was the option
being married or yeah being married to a
guy that went to prison I mean not a
great option no but or option
b do porn for a year become a social
media influencer and get pregnant with
an NBA player allegedly an NBA player
son right I guess on the bright side
she'll probably be paid out for 20 years
yeah
but I don't know I'm like in terms of
like respect life
satisfa you kind of respect El Chapo's
wife a little bit she's loyal you know
what I mean you know I mean God it's
kind of like you kind of have you seen
the CH you know what I'm talking about
she served like two years you're kind of
like
well right there's a
little so I want to get your take on
this video so she's talking actually now
about her how her view on men has
changed okay because her tune on men
before
was a bit they take advantage of me you
know they're so evil and bad and it's
not me making my own decisions but them
forcing me into those decisions okay
where I really think porn stars a lot of
them would work for free I think they're
bad business women right I think they
make like no money but but I genuinely
think they love the attention that it
brings them at the time but they don't
know the consequences that comes with it
that's my take okay so now she's talking
about how her view on men has changed
let's pull it up okay there's good guys
out there which by the way is another
thing that my pregnancy changed because
I had a boy I was very much a man hater
before I had my son and now I'm like I'm
still very much a girls girl but I'm
more of like an ally of all people
versus just women now because I look at
my son and how pure and innocent he is
and I'm like there's a little Milo and
all these men out there like they have a
mom that thinks about them the way that
I think about my son and that's really
helped me see that there are them a
little bit okay I mean she's being
honest good for her I
guess uh but yeah sorry I just can't
can't forget the way the the other one
was like yes same oh did you see who was
there I don't know who that is that's
Julia Fox oh my God is it s I couldn't
recognize her of course that's Julia Fox
I know I know that's what I
dominatrix we were just talking about
her before like she was like yeah same
that's my speciality actually but it's
interesting how you do see the mindset
shift a lot of times a bit when chicks
get older because they sort of realize
that maybe the man hatred wasn't all
that necessary yeah and and you know
like she said this is a pure innocent
Soul it's it's and and all men started
off like that believe it or not yeah and
guess what she's doing now also oh no
God what is it only F oh my God I swear
she has had a whole apology to her for
years what the hell years she has done a
whole apology to her saying I regret
this stuff that's a 18 180 I
and now she's but now she's only doing
the only fans that she doesn't feel
pressured into doing oh God so it's like
better right okay but it's sorry not a
180 that's a 360 isn't it she's just
going back to
school and and now with the child oh no
I know that's why when they give me
these ho apology tour I'm like I wanted
to believe it at first until I just see
so many of these chicks doing the same
thing they'll do the apology tour and
then start only fans yeah there is a
pattern definitely yeah and you know
this is what I say we really don't have
many gold standard women anymore so if
you are feeling unsure about your
finances these days you are not alone
that is why noble gold Investments is
here to help just hear it straight from
the folks that they have helped the
noble gold crew has walked me through
everything no stress and with their help
I can finally sleep easy at night and
now this month Noble gold Investments is
handing out a free 5 oz silver America
the Beautiful coin if you qualify for an
IRA investing gold and silver with Noble
gold Investments today go to noblegold
investments.com that's noblegold
investments.com they the only gold
company that I trust so you know there's
a lot of comments talking about what
this um chick was saying so she goes WTF
she went from a nine to a four yeah she
used to be a lot hotter like a lot but
it's interesting I feel like women that
make these choices hit the wall so much
quicker right like it's so interesting
they just age like I I like have you
seen like Pamela Anderson's another one
it just hits them hard because I don't
know if that's like cosmetic surgery or
well I don't know about that but yeah
definitely they look like they've been
through spends her life willingly being
an object for men and then complains at
how they treated her yeah no that's
that's how it is all the time you I'm
sorry but how old do you have to be to
start porn 18 yeah that that's it no
mistakes I'm sorry that's what I say
like because they always act like you're
18 you don't know what you're doing yeah
no no you you could say maybe you didn't
you know learn hard lessons but to act
like you didn't H like have any agency
in your decision yeah no because then
you're not being sincere you're not
being that crumbs the whole apology to
whatever I was a manher I think she
meant to say man
eater okay I don't know if that's an in
window or something I think it is
yeah damn she hit the wall she looks
like The Walking Dead good grief is that
she's got no makeup on but yeah I I
don't know I don't damn no makeup hit
yes oh my god oh no yeah but all of this
she she set she set herself up for all
of this yeah I don't know why where she
could have been married to a criminal
okay well even that could be debated we
don't even know the nature of well she
was could be innocent yeah yeah and she
was she was beautiful too so it wasn't
like that was her old choice no she was
cuz she was stunning back in the day she
was stunning what a shame but you know I
mean I even I was like even out of the
two options I was like I would still
pick if I had to pick married to a
criminal or ex porn star with a single
mother baby I I I would pick options and
only F Well yeah of course damn crazy
and and again what is
controlling what is controlling caring
about you trying to be
sensible yeah well because I think a lot
of times men have our best interests at
heart but because we're like because we
want to see them as the bad guy for
whatever reason it's like we take it as
controlling but really they're just
looking out for us yeah no exactly even
like I think of my dad every time my dad
has told me not to do something and I
have not listened he's always been right
yeah no same he's never he's never been
wrong say in maturity is when you
actually see that oh my dad cares about
me obviously yeah and my other half
cares about me yeah and and the thing is
like I don't think that coddling women
is kind no like I don't I don't think
it's like nice to us because it makes us
live in delusion yeah and I just think
reality is important and it and the
truth is important and that's why a lot
of people think I'm like mean or being
whatever but I'm like I I just think it
didn't help me to not know what was true
yeah it doesn't help Society to not know
what's true and we need to have and I'm
not saying I get it right 100% of the
time but we need to at least aim to talk
about what is true and that's why I
cannot stand um a lot of these movements
that have come up in the last couple of
years um and one of those I've seen is
really this push towards fat chicks and
magazines yes so Victoria Secret I used
to love I mean I would never watch the
Victoria Secret fashion show I'm not
going to lie but but I used to see we
did come on no I never I but I saw the
clips after I didn't have a TV growing
up oh wow yeah so we did we didn't have
TV so what um I would still see I had
social media so I would see it on
Facebook I loved being humble
oh that's what this was there for do you
know what I mean like you're supposed to
look at the TV and feel a little bad
about yourself I felt like it motivated
me we would print out the pictures put
them on the fridge I would want to get
on the treadmill more do you know what I
mean yeah well you got the height though
yeah yeah at least yes but come on
they're they're pretty hot you know what
I mean I mean I'm not going to pretend I
have never stood a chance against a
Victorious secret but they're too hot
though isn't it that's the issue that
they're finding well that's the that's
what I've noticed there's this whole
trend of the women getting less hot on
TV to be more relatable and I would
argue it's because they're making movies
and media for women now instead of men
yeah because all the men movies like
Transformers who's the chicken there
yeah I don't know who that is it was
Megan Fox oh yeah oh yeah of course yeah
and now she's kind of washed up now but
yeah and Margo Robbie like in her prime
was in Wolf of Wall Street and now she's
past her prime she's in movies for women
yeah so now she's in Barbie yep so um
yeah so Victoria Secret made a a huge
blunder when they decided to put fat
chicks um how can they not see this
coming I I don't know like that's what
they were that's what you were known for
yeah I I want to be humbled I want to
see the video and think yes that is that
well because you know I have a a little
bit of respect I have some respect
actually for Real Models yeah now I'm
not I know nowadays they're all IG
models but I'm like you know I used to
watch America's Next Top Model like some
of that stuff looks kind of hard all the
POS like you're supposed to be the
epitome of like elegance and Grace and
now they've just let she's a joke isn't
it like imagine if they let average
basketball players into the
NBA like the Victorious be secret used
to be the NBA
and now they just let they're like you
get in they're like Oprah you get in you
get in everyone gets in I don't know why
they haven't asked me
yet but um okay but anyway so now
Victoria's Secret is going back on that
and ditching woke in plus-size models
due to a decline in sales so let's pull
it yes oh God oh my God that's so bad
why would they be like that's so
bad is that two dudes in there yeah man
what does that tell you though they
don't care it's the money they thought
you know it's trending let's jump on
that and then as soon as they decline in
sales yeah out of no nope let's let's
see the new one oh yes they're back you
see that look at that they're beautiful
they're stunning yeah and at least like
at least they could give the normal
chick something to strive to the same
way it's you don't see man that average
basketball players protesting the NBA
and saying no no Take that down they're
too good I don't want to feel bad about
myself it's giving me trauma oh my God
no You' said that you said the
word so but like I don't know that's
just so this is beautiful yeah beautiful
and it it doesn't take away just like
just because we have to look at the best
people or or because they show the most
beautiful women in media it doesn't mean
you're ugly it doesn't mean you're
worthless it just means there's hotter
chicks than you yeah water is wet the
sky is blue don't take it
personal like I mean they'll be recycled
out for the next round be pissed though
if they ask me like can you come back
like what the hell but yes I
will moving a little bit back to the
family court system um what you know
about Steven
Crowder um I know that he was a he's
quite controversial yeah is he's like a
strict Christian is he strict yeah I
don't know yeah and uh advocate for
marriage yeah so well he was he was he
was he was oh no what happened so
Crowder um really I would say did
everything right he he actually waited
till he was married with his wife mhm um
to have sex and that actually made like
headline back in the day oh my God yeah
and he he ends up um doing the
traditional conservative route and he
gets married and he has two kids um
about six to eight months ago
now his wife released ring footage
accusing him of abuse oh no basically
Crowder and the daily wire were fighting
about a contract Crowder kind of pissed
off some people at the daily wire okay
so Crowder basically comes out and says
that he's divorcing or him and his wife
are getting divorced and he's being
blackmailed by the daily wire they they
deny this they say this is not true but
two days later Candace Owens releases
spring footage from his private
residence no way and says that and has a
video titled Steven Crowder is a monster
no way yes yes so I I don't know if he
was or who wasn't and then she says this
is preposterous I can't believe you
accus me of this I'm only releasing ing
this because you said that you're you're
you're playing the victim here you're
you're acting like your wife is in the
wrong divorcing you um why she doesn't
get to give her side of the story I'll
let her her give her side of the story
on my platform wow she releases ring
footage accusing Crowder of abuse suar
and the thing is me because I I I know
these type of cases I knew what she was
doing whenever these chicks release ring
footage to the public it's like
why is why are you why are you like you
never know the reasoning behind the clip
and months later I find out like I I
have a source reach out to me and give
me the full context behind the clip in
the clip he basically says to his wife
you need to listen to me and he was kind
of being moany and like whining at her
about it and then she says he goes into
the house and says I'll [__] you up so
that sounds like abuse I get the
recording version with the full footage
in the house and right after he says I'm
sorry I'm sorry too
far wow so is that really the abusive
and they left that bit out obviously yes
yes and the thing is Candace never
reported the new information and so all
of conservative Twitter and in like she
ruined his reputation accusing him of
abuse all of this stuff and really and
then I get the affidavit later where she
admits in court he was not abusive
Candace ens no not Candace the wife
sorry the wife later admits in court he
was not abusive okay but the damage has
been done the damage has been done that
was the whole point and it was
unfortunate cuz I love Candace Owens but
she was just so wrong in this and I
don't know why the daily wire hasn't
issued a retraction or at least reported
on the new
information um but regardless um
regardless so Crowder before he was
married had a very different tune on the
men that fear marriage and right now
there's a clip going viral of his
changes in tune after this whole thing
let's pull it up we've talked about this
a lot that the incels right the
involuntary celibates the professionally
outraged over alimon and child support
payment crowd sorry I'm not on board
with you you know what you need to learn
to be the person that your woman's going
to want when wolves are at the
[Music]
door
yeah and and that's the thing like they
think we're celebrating and we're not
we're not celebrating like I would never
celebrate this sort of thing but it's
like you don't know until you know
exactly I mean that's it's horrible for
him to do that to fellow men like just
because he hasn't been through yet and
then voila uh he now he knows he's red
pilled have you seen this before uh the
Steven Crowder thing yeah um I actually
did see the footage but even then I was
just like you have to see the whole
thing don't do not just give us a clip
of that because obviously and we know
the bigger picture why they're doing it
the plan but the average Layman would be
like oh yeah see he said something in a
in a you know questionable tone but
that's not good enough now you know we
need to see the full picture well and
the other thing is he was assuming he
said just be the person your wife needs
you to be something like that he's
assuming we're reasonable people yeah
yeah like we're not guys you know what I
mean you know I'm like you're assuming
the woman that they married is
reasonable yeah and so now you have this
girl she waited till she was married she
was a Christian she was thin she was
beautiful
like yeah but what else was he supposed
to do he found the good woman that
prayed
and
then so I I was more asking though have
you know being in the work that you do
um how do you see men typically get red
pill oh uh exactly like this exactly
like this a lot of times they would be
like um you know oh uh they're so in
love with their wife and being a husband
and everything and then they just think
guys are being bitter or being
overreactive and then they go in they go
through it and they're just like
suddenly they just realize everything is
against them yeah and then they you know
it's like growing list it's like a
growing club yeah of people who like you
know wow I I had no idea and and they
learned the lesson the hard way and it's
sad it's very sad because most of the
time I I always hear well they shouldn't
sleep around and do all this stuff but
in my experience and maybe you might
have a different one it is not the men
that slept around and were like complete
[__] and all that stuff that this
happens to no it's actually mostly the
men that want to do the right thing
absolutely my god I've spoken to more
like I would say I've spoken to so many
men who have been a good devoted husband
and and and this is not just me being
biased I'm extremely objective about
this by the way and there are a lot of
women who even go through difficulties
and no we're not denying that whatsoever
but it is so
astronomically men who suffer and and it
it's so sad because they are so innocent
in terms of yeah you know I I want to be
a good father I want to be a good
husband and they just get so just just
backhanded by their wife or their
girlfriend or whatever and then um and
then the system being that you're in law
school and there's a lot of lawyers that
actively like sign up to do this you
know how does this happen like like what
what's your experience and like what
circumstances create these situations
money it's all about money money
absolutely I think back when in the 80s
or 90s back then um that's when lawyers
law firms were actually paying attention
to the family court system before then
they didn't
really it it wasn't really um common for
law firms to have a family court section
where they family law yeah because it
wasn't lucrative back then but now it's
such big business that every single law
fir has a you know well not every single
one but mainly now it's the norm to have
a family law section and because
obviously the house the house is the
biggest asset and so if you get that
sold big money guaranteed
guaranteed and that's why the men never
get the house yeah never yeah very rare
cases I've never heard of a guy getting
the house yeah I I can't think of one
and you know what's interesting they
call them incels but they have kids I
know that's why I'm like they're like
these bitter incels I'm like Noels
wouldn't even get in the door with I
they're having flipping loads of
children and stuff like again I find
that the typical archetype of the men
that I've interviewed as a guy that has
a normal job and really just wants to be
a father and do the right thing yeah
it's not these it's not these guys that
are getting all the ladies if anything I
would say and i' I've talked to a couple
men that were like you know high-end
business owners athletes or whatever
that went through the same thing yeah
but I would say if I had to guess those
guys can keep the women a little bit
better than the average man yeah if I if
I had to guess um and you know guys you
know I have heard that one way to
protect your assets in divorce and we're
going to do a show on this soon is to
get gold that women don't know about so
if you want to take control of your
financial future but you don't know
where to start Noble gold Investments
understands investing in Precious Metals
may sound confusing but the team at
Noble gold makes Investments easy let's
hear from actual Noble gold investment
customers the staff answered all of my
questions and helped me every step of
the way no pressure sales tactics just
honest guidance securing my future is
less stressful thanks to Noble Golds
expertise so don't settle for financial
uncertainty they'll suggest options and
see if you can diversify into gold and
silver
right now Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 5 o Silver America the
Beautiful bullion coin for qualified
accounts don't settle for financial
uncertainty Noble gold Investments has a
A+ rating with the Better Business brew
and countless five-star reviews why wait
go to noblegold investments.com now
that's noblegold investments.com the
only gold company that I trust again you
know we just have this trend towards not
living in reality you know and you know
going back to the body positivity
movement what happened to
PE do you guys did you guys have PE here
yeah we used to like mess around in PE
yeah I have no idea what it's like now
but they they used to like actually it's
interesting if you look at videos from
like the 70s and 80s yeah they used to
have all these like push-up contests you
had to make PE requirements yeah yeah
and now it's just like games like
there's no real they got rid of PE in
high school it's not very competitive no
okay not physically challenging which
probably is the point okay and so
there's a video that's going viral um
from the 1960s talking about PE at
school pull it
up people are shocked at what American
High School gym class looked like in the
1960s this footage is from one of the
4,000 us high schools that followed
Laser's physical education program that
was pushed to be the standard model by
JFK according to the lasierra physical
education standards that were outlined
in their 1966 handbook the minimum
push-ups that a student should be able
to do is 16 and they should have at
least a 7 and 1/2 minute mile run
considering most modern Americans
struggle to even complete five push-ups
this 16 minimum is quite shocking the
top group that was outlined in the
handbook is blue team and to be a part
of this you had to be able to preform 12
handstand push-ups dfk man isn't that
crazy that's crazy they were in such
good shape I think now people will think
that's like they're preparing for the
Army or something but that's just in
high
school just your typical high school gym
class that's amazing it's interesting to
see beach pictures from them too cuz now
you see like so many overweight chubby
big people but then everyone was in
shape yeah and it's like healthy happy
it says when men used to be men all
right ladies we're OB obese too all
right that's all right but yeah I'm kids
today would cry if you were asked to do
this I would cry I couldn't do that I
not but this shit's dumb of course fat
it's probably fat of
course what why do you think we're so
fat today what do you think
happened just I mean there's just so
much too it's just I don't know food's a
lot crapper now come on and and
and they say isn't it like oh oh I think
one of the reasons um there was this fat
YouTuber she was talking about well I'm
I'm overweight because I can't afford
good food I was like come on I'm you
know you can make your own meals and
stuff and well we can go into all the
boring bits but um the food's really
crap what the heck is PE Now everywhere
you see fat people are being
glorified so well how many of those
chicks order takeout that can't afford
food yeah exactly so expensive
exactly yeah and I just think it's of
EXC
we think alike we think like this is why
this is why your fan
favorite yeah um yeah and this
is this is what drives me nuts it's like
it's almost sad it's like Eerie to look
back on because really I think that the
food's been poisoned because of the Love
of Money yeah yeah and even like you
know they're saying birth controls like
in the water now have you heard that
they're saying like basically like all
of the birth control pollutes the water
are you drinking tap water um I usually
drink bottles yes stay away from tap
water people bottles yeah but yeah I
mean I I will cook with it sometimes I'm
sorry I'm sorry guys I'm sorry boil it
first what boil it first I do I do boil
I do boil the water but but you know but
even that it's like what what caused
that the love of money yeah they can
make a whole industry off of birth
control and you know what's sad I had a
nanny back in the day who was like I
still remember her to this day as one of
like my favorite nanny I was so close
with this nanny and she ended up not
being able to have kids because of a
birth control shot oh my God so she
never had kids she got married and then
she just she's still married but she
could never have kids man but it's like
all of it just seems like all of these
problems are like it's caused really by
the Love of Money yeah and you said it
yourself what did you tell me before the
show about the lawyers um the reason
they did law school oh yeah it's just
it's just money yeah well you said they
asked your class that right oh yeah yeah
yeah and I was the only one that was
like oh you know want to do the right
thing but I did I didn't say it because
you know I don't want now it to be
singled out and stuff you're trying to
graduate I
know um I was like yeah yeah yeah money
yeah
yeah um okay well thank you very much
for coming on today thanks for inviting
me it was fun yeah very much fun um tell
the people where they can can find you
and support your organization uh yes so
my Instagram is the female skeptic and I
do have a YouTube channel but that's
kind of I'm I I'm working on it and uh
the organization I work for is split the
difference.com and we're planning to
take the CMS to court a very very big
operation yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm going to
cover it when you guys do it I think
that's awesome you love that keep me
posted um all right guys make sure you
like the video on your way out guys a
like is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so make sure you get this to 2,000 likes
also guys get yourself a women should
vote t-shirt today you already know my
opinion all of the world's problems are
caused by women voting so if you want to
end this today get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt all the women
will come up to you left and right and
just say how awesome you are like the
video on your way out guys subscribe to
the channel and we'll talk to you next
time